Einstein may be the brightest
mind I have yet taught.
He's a menace!
[explosion]
You are skipping classes and
challenging your instructors.
What I want to
know, Sir, is why.
My name is Professor
Philipp Lenard.
Herr Professor.
Mileva Maric.
One doesn't lose track of
the sole woman in the room.
She's up all night,
filling her brain with things
I can't begin to understand.
Then how do you know
she understands them?
I'm head over heels
in love with your mind.
You're my partner
in life and love
and endless scientific pursuit.
How is Marie?
Everyone is quite excited.
About what?
The courtship, of course.
The potential of it!
I'm going to be a professor.
I will think for
thinking's sake.
That is the most indulgent
thing I've ever heard.
Well, don't leave
like this, Albert.
Liar!
How could you be so
careless with my heart?
Physics should
be an adventure.
That's enough!
Fail him if you must.
I am no longer concerned
for his future.
Mitta!
Hello, Papa.
I'm so sorry, Papa.
I failed you.